from Stanford David Shaw good to see you
sir how are you I'm great can't wait for
tonight I know I mean we were just
talking about it in the in the
commercial break this is lit this town
is just lit right now it's out of
control people are coming in from
everywhere everybody's having a great
time the hospitality has been off the
charts it has been awesome and then you
know you and I we were broadcasting from
the the makeshift set that they created
to look like an extension of Tutsis on
Broadway and just looking down the
street it it's amazing it's just truly
amazing the people who are walking in I
think the NFL has done an unbelievable
job of promoting this this this entire
event it's gotten bigger and better
every single year it has alright let's
get into the evening do you think
calamari goes first it's the only thing
that makes sense for all the moves that
they made up until this point right
folks including drafting Josh frozen
last year everything else they've done
since then right would lead you to
believe that this is the thing that
makes sense from from hiring the coach
that they hired bringing in the
philosophy and this quarterback seems to
fit exactly what they want to do it okay
and then what they've done since the
combo like I know you need to be coy in
case you get that that Godfather offer
that you can't refuse for the first
overall pick and you do need to I
understand make it seem like you would
take that guy to try and get somebody to
get up there but you also have to know
if you're evaluating that certain
systems in certain coaches they're never
gonna go up and get this guy because of
his lip literal stature not his
figurative stature in his tape so that's
kind of a head-scratcher if they if they
maneuver all this way and then don't
take him first overall there would have
to be a very powerful voice somewhere in
that organization that would have had to
convince pretty much everybody else that
this is not the thing to do that we
should do something else so we have to
believe in Josh Rosen and the other
combination out weapons that we have on
the offensive side maybe we need to take
Joe of both so we need to take somebody
else but I think that would be shocking
at this point knowing Rosen as you do
obviously haven't competed against him
how do you he's he's he hasn't said a
single thing other than just putting out
a video of him and his buddies where he
does speak from the heart
about how annoying this has been but how
do you think he would handle it
if they come to him and just say
look we told you the combine you're our
guy personally but sorry about the last
two and a half months how do you think
he would handle that do you think
knowing knowing uh Josh's I do know
going although back to recruiting him I
think he's shown unbelievable restraint
he's been one of the most outspoken guys
in college football in the beginning of
the NFL career and realizing that this
is a job and he's got a persona that
he's been trying to change to a certain
degree he believes in himself 100% as a
lot of people do that he is going to be
a very good NFL quarterback and if it's
in Arizona great if it's not it's gonna
be someplace else and all the reports
you hear from him showing up every
single day working extremely hard
learning the offense being a leader on
the field for those guys he's done
everything that he needs to do and now
the things that other people have to do
let them do that and if if he it has to
stay in Arizona okay great but it's not
gonna be very long if they take kind of
Murray but he's gonna go someplace else
I think he's got a very good bead on
what it takes to be professional right
now which is show up and do your job
now that you could all that said though
I mean he's still a human being and you
know I've heard stories about how
quarterbacks have their like elephants
their memories are they it never dies
yeah I mean there's no question about it
and this kids in that category don't
think he doesn't have a huge chip on his
shoulder anyway for all the guys were
drafted in front of him anyone who
remembers all those guys didn't I say
that all the teams made nine mistakes in
front of him yes yes
which may or may not be true but the
most important thing though that you're
alluding to is he's got the edge he's
got a chip on his shoulder no matter
what they do whether he stays in Arizona
or not right his kids already got a chip
on his shoulder he's dying to prove his
ability not just to survive in this game
he thinks he wants to he's gonna be one
of the best that's what he has in his
mind it's just who's gonna give him that
opportunity Arizona or someplace else
and they're just being having sat next
to you now for eight years and I kind
I'm kind of getting an idea of the way
your mind thinks David Shaw youth you'd
like Rosen and are a little bit confused
why they would move on from him after
taking him am i putting words in your
mouth or do you believe no I I
understand
and I'd like to remind people and I did
nine years in the NFL before I came back
to college yes and you make
organizational decisions when you make
an organizational decision like this
this franchise has made and hiring the
head coach that they hired you can't
worry about what happened before that so
you can't worry that you took a
quarterback in the first run last year
if you've made an organizational
decision to change how you're gonna play
this offense and you want a specific
type of guy to play quarterback there
right then you don't worry about what
you did last year now I can't say that
that's completely happened but I'm by
all accounts that's is what happened
they've made an organizational decision
to play a certain style of offense and
this quarterback like it or not his
stature whatever he is proven that he
can play in this offense at an extremely
high level so it would it would be
shocking to me if they seemed they went
down this road with the head coach and
the philosophy and then all of a sudden
changed to the last minute so what was
the dice decision in a draft room that
you were witness to in your years in the
NFL that might even be remotely similar
to something like this where the
organization has to sit down and say do
we really want to do this and we have to
explain it to player X if we do do you
recall so I think it's been long enough
for me to actually tell the story
publicly now I love the win stories
begin that way David Shaw because god
bless all davis I miss him all the time
and he's a special special human being
and a brilliant man and his in his in
his in his role but we had a long long
three week discussion about Sebastian
Janikowski you know do we need a
receiver do we need an offensive lineman
or do we need a kicker and to take a
kicker in the first round and that takes
an organizational it takes the owner to
walk in and say we're taking the kicker
in the first round that's what it takes
and that's what we had and we were split
as an organization there was a lot of
discussion back and forth but al Davis
the boss set the tempo and we end up
taking a Hall of Fame kicker that was
outstanding it was he was he was a
phenomenal pick as hard as it was at the
time we were making a decision to play
field position we had a guy who's gonna
kick the ball out of the back of the
endzone almost every single kick and
who's gonna make 50-yard Plus field
goals like they were chip shots and then
taking Shane LeClair later in the draft
who was going to help also dominate
field position with the way that he
punted the ball so we had two guys that
changed field position once again it's
hard for a head coach or a position
to make that decision the owner has to
say this is how we're going to play and
we made those those two picks work and
those two guys came in and we're
outstanding I think they should both be
Hall of Famers well I mean lek look just
retired and I think you know sea bass is
just about to I think as well so that's
how long that they did last can you give
me any glimpse of what the conversation
was like in the room for something like
that without all Davis at the front of
it I mean my gosh oh the room got warm a
couple times you know because because
here we were with coach Gruden we came
in and took over a four and twelve team
that needed a lot of positions need a
lot of change we needed to score more
points we had Tim Brown that we thought
could still play at a high level we knew
we needed a quarterback thankfully
wouldn't got Rich Gannon which is I was
outstanding but we needed a lot of
things and to sit there on a four and
twelve team to say gosh we need a kicker
that was a hard thing to take for a lot
of lot of scouts a lot of coaches to say
we need so many other things other than
this kicker but right al Davis and his
forth his foresight said there hasn't
been a kicker like this ever there's
never been a guy like this is 260 pounds
that likes to hang out on Bourbon Street
and come in and just bomb kickoffs and
bomb field goals just kick baby this is
like the perfect Oakland Raider ever and
and and he said I could we cannot pass
up this opportunity to take a guy that
might be one of the best ever to play
the position I don't care if it's kicker
or not we're gonna take up coach David
Shaw of Stanford here on the Rich Eisen
show again he'll be part of the NFL
Network first-round coverage tonight
8:00 eastern time 7:00 la 7 o'clock
straight up here in Nashville and now
here's Gruden Raider coach again our guy
mike Mayock is his general manager
sitting in the room and the amount of
chatter I'm hearing that they have
pushed Haskins and or Murray up their
draft board do you believe that they're
gonna go quarterback knowing Gruden as
you do Antonio Brown just came would
they really go and take a rookie
quarterback first overall for them
fourth overall do you think first of all
mr. Davis would be so proud that there's
this much chat about what the Oakland
Raiders are gonna do okay that's it
there's this moment Johnny absolutely
there's much intrigue as much what are
these guys gonna do when they have all
these first-round picks are going to
trade it up trade it back take a
quarterback where they can do it their
car al Davis would love this confusion
that's around what they're doing so
kudos to those guys
and beyond that I wouldn't put it past
him policy I wouldn't put it past him I
think there's a lot of great feelings
forward Derek Carr and what he's been
able to do in kid the kids played at a
high level also this is not a bad
quarterback this guy's a good
quarterback right he's athletic he's
smart he looks like a great fit for John
Gruden's type of an offense but that's
not saying that this wouldn't happen so
I think that's where pushing the scouts
out and trying to keep the chatter out
yeah and and really making this a
two-man show between Mayock and Gruden
it's really no telling what they're
gonna do but I would not be shocked
because once again John Gerdes got a
long-term contract
yes he does he's thinking more than
about the next five minutes he's
thinking about how we're gonna finish
off this time in Oakland how we're gonna
start our time in Las Vegas he's
thinking more like management and
ownership as well as as the head coach
so this is this pick whatever it is
going to be I believe it's gonna be a
long term long term pick well we'll make
sure let's extrapolate this out a little
bit more than so the sense that Gruden
does not like young quarterbacks you
only want to work with veterans is that
is that uh is that fallacious is that
accurate that is that is a moniker that
John actually hates he really hates that
what John likes is quarterbacks that
grow and listen and do what they're
supposed to do and play the position at
a high level and a guy that doesn't mind
being pushed and a lot of young
quarterbacks you know you kind of have
to use kid gloves a little bit to kind
of help him grow right John doesn't own
kid gloves he doesn't even know what
those things are John when you walk in
the door you were going to get pushed
and John wants to push you and push you
and push you and you engage with that
and you accept that where I take the
challenge on that because people say
that but then I think he started
Grotowski
young at Tampa who's kind of a guy he
was a tough guy he was a smart guy John
could push him hard and he would respond
and play a play well so that that
moniker that John's been labeled with I
I know he hates it and I know why
because he just says I want to whoever's
gonna play this game at a high level
that's who I want okay so let's say he
does choose Marie or Haskins they'd have
to play him now because if he is talking
about the you know finishing up Oakland
and starting off well in Vegas they're
not gonna just throw a rookie out there
and hope that he's Pat mahomes after a
year of seasoning on the sidelines right
I mean they're gonna have to get him up
to speed and get him going with mr. big
chess and figuring out how it's gonna
work
which by the way that's the only way to
refer to him as mr. bicha that's what he
said to call him so I do an Antonia
brown says and if you're out there on
Instagram live what's up baby so what
what do you what do you think if they do
something like that so here's the most
interesting thing to me different than
the Arizona situation where you'll be
drafting a quarterback that's so vastly
different from the one that you have
there so night and day if you took one
of those two quarterbacks you're talking
about guys that have been efficient in
the pocket who can not necessarily not
everybody can run like Kyle Emery but I
think Haskins has been mislabeled as a
statue this guy moves oh just well
enough to in the pocket much like a dare
car so these two guys if you if you took
one of these two guys and you kept their
car there's a chance Derek Carr could
still be the starters you train and
groomer you not know the young man much
like Patrick Mahone's much like they did
in Green Bay much like he's done a brown
around the league so it wouldn't be I
have to play two completely different
offenses Derek Carr can go there and
play and play great with one of these
guys learning behind him so before I let
you go and Daniel Jeremiah who is going
to be again sitting at the end of the
set that we're hanging out on in the NFL
Network of first round coverage 8:00
Eastern Time tonight who's the one guy
that you see that you'd if you were in a
draft room and you'd be pounding the
table you've fallen in love with even if
you don't have a shot to go get that
person who's the one in the draft that
you've you've looked at you go that's
the one I I love this there are a few
but there's one guy that I just can't I
can't stop thinking about as Christian
Wilkins at Clemson here's a guy with a
big personality he's big he's strong
he's quick he's athletic he's got great
leadership ability graduated from
Clemson in three years and working on a
second degree he's one of those guys
that seems to have life figured out
you're not taking a young guy that has
to learn what to do this guy's this he
can play the game at a high level but
you also have to worry about him off the
field I think this guy's gonna be a
mainstay he's gonna be the key to
somebody's success down the road and
then to bring this all full circle we
buried the lead
because you led with this when I sat
down next to you at our dress rehearsal
when we first saw each other here in
Nashville for this draft week you turned
to me and you said to me that you had
what for me I got a punter for you had a
boy yes you do and the punter you have
for me in the draft is what's the name
of this gentleman
Jake Bailey Jake Bailey Jake Bailey's
from Southern California
just like we talked about when we're
talking about Al Davis and they can
decide to play this field position game
yes sir Jake Bailey is one of the best
kick-off artists and coming out of
college by the way thank you for calling
him an artist yes because kickers are
artists too it is an artichoke you know
it is a weapon you go coach it is a
weapon and what cake was able to do as a
kickoff artist kicking the ball down the
field kicking out at the back of the end
zone making people start not giving
those great kickoff returns and hop up
in the nflp route you don't give those
guys a chance to influence the game yes
and then beyond that I wasn't
outstanding and there's some things that
I know al Davis was loved outstanding
put the ball inside the ten inside the
5-yard line
changing field position and one of the
big parts of the game of the year in a
jig did have his best game in the bowl
game but to come back just when we
needed it to pin the offense back inside
their 5-yard line and in the fourth
quarter that's game over you've got a
guy that can flip field position like
that just like we talked about receivers
I can change field position yeah we got
punters that can change but I just love
your passion I can hear it it's real
football and and Jake I think is is
highly coveted by a lot of teams I don't
know how high yeah what do you think
woody would you know tomorrow night
maybe I wouldn't say that I would say
somewhere around I've heard a lot of
fifth round but I wouldn't be surprised
if somebody tried to take him a little
earlier because that position is that
important okay great to see you I'm
really excited if you sit next to you
again on draft night looking down at
your handwritten notes on on your iPad
that's that's I've never really seen
that that's the same city your desk and
you write everything out and then what
them then you send it to somebody who
puts it on your iPad no III write it all
on the iPad it's up in the cloud so if I
ever lose my iPad I can just plug back
in and get and get it all back there so
I have all my stuff dating back to our
first draft okay but absolutely got it
all and you write notes about what I do
do you evaluate more now I'm nervous
about tonight David Shaw of Stanford a
man who I love to sit next to and who
will absolutely give my children a
letter of intent of tomorrow right for
what the class of 2025 and 27 it's in
the mail right my kid turn to be there
today said you know I want to go to
Stanford I'm like not the way you do
your homework
no I'm not putting them on the crew team
great to see you David Shaw Thanks okay
Daniel Jeremiah when we come back here
live on the Rich Eisen show for more of
the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel - 39 on DirecTV for free on be
our live or download the Rich Eisen show
app